[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
faire de la RSE un atout pour les
entreprises
en matière de RSE les attentes sont
grandissantes les entreprises le savent
la responsabilité sociale et
environnementale représentent un réel
enjeu de compétitivité une intense
production normative européenne et
française imposent aux entreprises un
agenda très serré
d'énormes exigent des entreprises la
publication de données de plus en plus
diverses notamment extra-financières
ce processus cumulatif non coordonné
inquiète les entreprises et tout
particulièrement les entreprises de
taille intermédiaires les et les petites
et moyennes entreprises les PME dans ces
conditions comment donner à chaque
entreprise les outils pour se
transformer face aux enjeux de leur
responsabilité sociétale et leur
permettre de lutter à armes égales avec
les entreprises non-européennes pour
relever ce défi Martine Berthet Florence
blatrix compta et Jacques leney dans
leur rapport réalisé au nom de la
délégation aux entreprises présentent 12
recommandations afin de mettre
réellement la RSE à la portée de toutes
les entreprises
les rapporteurs après avoir rencontré
des entrepreneurs à travers toute la
France avertissent au lendemain de la
crise sanitaire et face à des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en matière première
les entreprises pourraient se voir
contraintes ou tenter de reléguer leurs
efforts en matière de RSE au second rang
il est donc urgent d'agir
la délégation suggère avant tout que
l'État fournisse une étude d'impact du
coût financier et organisationnel par
catégorie d'entreprises du cumul des
obligations nationales et européennes en
matière de RSE le rapport préconise de
poser un principe de proportionnalité du
contenu des informations
extra-financières demandées en fonction
de la taille et des moyens de
l'entreprise afin de permettre à toutes
les entreprises de répondre aux
exigences de la future directive
relative aux informations
extra-financières qui doivent être
fournies par les entreprises la
délégation conseil notamment
d'accompagner les ETI et PME
parallèlement le rapport recommande de
mieux utiliser le levier de la commande
publique pour diffuser plus largement
les critères ESG environnement sociétés
et gouvernance qui sont au cœur de la
mutation du modèle d'affaires des
entreprises
la RSE revêt clairement un enjeu de
souveraineté afin d'éviter une main mise
des agences de notation sous contrôle
étrangers de défendre l'autonomie
européenne de la RSE et d'imposer les
valeurs européennes de l'entreprise les
rapporteurs recommandent de confier à
l'autorité européenne des marchés
financiers l'évaluation publique de
l'information ESG enfin la délégation
souhaite faire progresser la culture RSE
dans les conseils d'administration aussi
bien que dans la formation en
labellisant les écoles de commerce et
d'ingénieurs engagés dans une démarche
d'enseignement obligatoire des enjeux de
la RSE et de la transition climatique
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]